un début de saison estivale qui a des
airs de retour à la normale pour les
affaires le pire est derrière nous
assure ce commerçant
mais il déplore l'absence prolongée de
bons clients et touristes canadiens
surtout les québécois qui en temps
normal sont nombreux à choisir le maine
comme destination de vacances 4,4 des
mots en français qu'il n'a pas eu
l'occasion pratiqué depuis la fermeture
de la frontière entre le canada et des
états unis en mars 2020 on s'ennuie à ce
modèle les québécois représente en temps
normal de 40 à 60 % de la clientèle vide
que les touristes américains ne comble
pas les québécois ils prennent 3 5 jours
est une semaine donc ces différences
c'est beaucoup c'est un gros changement
pour nous aussi
d'abord vacances de deux jours des
américains qui de proche
elle suit donc avec attention
l'évolution des discussions autour de la
frontière canado américaine dont la
fermeture la prive de nombreuses
réservations
c'est beaucoup
cette impatience exprimées par des
acteurs du secteur touristique est
partagée par des élus des démocrates et
des républicains et du maine sur la côte
est à l'état de washington sur la côte
ouest en passant par new york
ignorent-ils sept états de la nouvelle
angleterre comme le maine et le vermont
voisin a l'un des taux de vaccinations
les plus élevés au pays
plus de la moitié de la population du
new hampshire a reçu ces deux doses
un argument en faveur d'une réouverture
sécuritaire des voyages non essentiels à
la frontière selon le gouverneur de
l'état
c'est important pour l'économie les
familles et les loisirs dit l'élu qui
propose même de partager des doses
excédentaires avec le canada mais
comment vérifier si un voyageur
transfrontalier est vraiment vacciner le
gouverneur républicain qui se pose lui
même à l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale
crois que la réouverture de la frontière
ne peut pas attendre l'issue d'un tel
débat politiquement sensible aux états
unis chose certaine les pressions des
élus d'états frontaliers se font
ressentir jusqu'à washington
de quoi influencer la prise de décisions
congrès mais aussi au sein de la maison
blanche de joe biden joël le vent est
donc en train de tourner aux états unis
en faveur de la relance des activités à
la frontière pays états et provinces
sont toujours en pourparlers
des tractations qui détermineront quand
les voyageurs canadiens déferleront de
nouveau sur les causes humaines
ici rafale bouvier auclair radio canada